[Music]
oh marvel we send you for not having
moon knight in the intro to his own show
and you respond by putting him in the
intro to miss marvel so did you also put
miss marvel in the intro to your miss
marvel tv show i don't think so now i
must marvel that marvel missed the
marvelous miss marvel in marvel's miss
marvel making marvel's miss marvel intro
marvel s listen gamala thor was clearly
still rocking his thunder gut during the
battle for earth so i don't appreciate
the revisionist god-bod representation
and the resulting body image pressure
but also what's up with his evil eyebrow
angry thorman giant's bane face let the
conspiracies commence because that is
not four six one six
stapling an enemy's oofy doodah bits
i love this but my eyes are hurting and
my jump cuts need therapy why is the
podcast start a rectangle three thousand
by three thousand scott three thousand
by three thousand having two documents
with the same title on your desktop mere
inches away from each other unrealistic
representations of upload time for
videos remember new episodes drop every
wednesday unrealistic content
expectations don't let the content beast
eat you alive kamala or else you might
find yourself sitting in front of a
computer trying desperately to stay
relevant and funny while delivering five
pieces of content a week and wondering
where the last decade went you know just
as an example this wayward string it
beckons me it asks for cutting it asks
for pulling just take care of it kamala
please don't forget to look at the
mirrors every 15 seconds at least 15
seconds five to eight seconds is the
recommended standard for checking your
car's mirrors and an overprotective mom
would absolutely know that
you've seen this student driver crashes
into a car that just happens to be the
car of their instructor cliche so many
times i'm pretty sure you didn't even
need to have him say that's my car when
we were well aware of that the moment it
happened 10 seconds earlier marvel
continued showing us the new york city
skyline but not giving us any info on
the current state or ownership of
avengers tower i've read the guidebook
to toxic fandom and it clearly states
you owe us every piece of information
that we ask for so spill i get it high
school sucks for most people but does
every single coming of age tale ever
told need to hit us over the head with
this forced never-ending lineup of
consecutive cringe encounters the second
our protagonist walks through the door
putting the nose before bruno's name in
your encanto
reference i really do love you you're
also apparently clairvoyant because
that's the only way you would have known
kamala already knew about the driving
test bet the entire school seems to be a
sort of billboard for information and
there are zero ticks drawn on the
posters in a high school impossible very
funny very talented surely the art
teacher can look past the utenta horns
and recognize and appreciate the
artistry then you're going to look
yourself in the mirror and you're going
to ask yourself kamala who is that girl
i see
staring
straight back at me choosing reflection
instead of i'll make a man out of you i
know fantasy's fun fantasy is really fun
but right now i need you to pull
yourself together
and join reality this is get your head
out of the clouds cliche so hard right
now i have expected the thing to pop
around the corner and ponder his big
strong hands before kamala flies away on
the luck dragon from chongqi he's not
going to be another first avenger khan
ever again oh yes the shortsightedness
of youth the first isn't always the most
exciting or memory worthy trust me i'm
sorry is he airbrushing a costume in a
convenience store so can we stop acting
like your mom is darth vader referencing
encounter mulan and star wars within
five minutes of each other if we get a
national geographic reference in the
next five minutes i'm calling disney
plus bingo
why ride through someone's ball game
certainly there are roads that you can
stay on i mean maybe not for the sweet
cinematic shot we have going on at the
moment but in real life there's no
reason to bike through is this from nani
it must be thanks for the bath book one
thing i'm really loving in this show is
the cultural immersion guessing most
people don't know what about pocky is
and the show doesn't care to explain it
we just move on because it's normal with
the characters and that's that it's rare
to feel invited into a new cultural
experience and not have everything
overexplained to the point of
distraction [ __ ] love this they
charge you for extra stuff
guys yes the halal guys is a real place
and yes i'm adding us in because it
looks delicious and the closest one is
currently 400 miles away from me but no
one here seems to be addressing is that
if bruno just made them this and is
showing them how it works then he must
have also either bought and installed
them smart lights throughout the entire
house without their knowledge or hacked
into their electricity at the source
zuzu switch to a sports channel kinsuzu
reminds because i don't care what
television package you have you've got
more than one sports channel this would
be like saying zuzu tell that story
about the time i embarrassed myself so
immensely i had to move to a new city
zuzu's gonna need a few more details to
narrow it down knock please right
always knock i don't care who you are or
who you think is or isn't on the other
side doors are shut for a reason adam
connecting your messaging app to your
starfield projector so that everyone can
see your text on your ceiling stopping
in the middle of the road to check your
phone
i don't know which is more convenient
that this full-length robe just happened
to be sitting right there or that her
mom's suspicion meter doesn't go off
immediately and keep us from the
inevitable and already tiresome
misunderstanding gets worse conversation
honestly these she-hulk promotions are
getting a bit out of control at least
the effects look better here though
maybe on the roof in ten and she does
meaning somehow her parents were super
okay with her biking to see her buddy at
night just after a dramatic and
emotional family fall out i just don't
get the impression they would be okay
with that my mom my teachers mr wilson
he prefers gabe kamala
oh bruno corelli corporations i like it
it has a nice ring to it no that says b
corelli it rhymes that's why it has a
nice ring to it
kamala please tell bruno the zuzu is
possessed by the evil gin if you were
gonna do the actual light bulb turns on
above a character's head when they have
an idea cliched did you really have to
shove it down our ocular cavities by
adding the animation as well we get it
you've seen a mel brooks movie deadpool
effectively destroyed the hero landing
for good six years ago and even the mcu
mocked it in black widow so i don't care
if this three-point landing is done
seriously for jokes or even a meta
commentary all three things have been
done better elsewhere so maybe just stop
doing them i'll sneak back into my room
just before my dad comes in at 9 22 p.m
that is a very specific time for your
dad to come into your room does it mean
something is there something you're
trying to tell us about september 22nd
the salem witch trials had their final
executions on september 22nd that's it
it's clear kamala will be accused of
witchcraft by the end of the season and
stand trial where she-hulk and matt
murdock will defend her quit making your
easter egg so obvious marvel all this
and that's her note really did she
casually draw this during science class
has everyone gone home for the day and
they lingered for the chalkboard and
somehow the teacher was super fine with
that and that is why the salamanders are
almost extinct in pakistan i think we're
supposed to feel for kamala here who
seems bored by this conversation but
animal extinction is interesting and
important what's avenger con when you
could be educated on amphibian
conservation
this is supposed to be the real world
right kabbalah literally just did a head
first dive to grab a branch on a tree
two stories in the air as if this is
just a normal thing teenagers do and
sneaking out of the house why would she
do this is she aware she's wearing about
six layers of plot armor also convenient
pile of leaves that still wouldn't break
the fall enough to do much is convenient
stopping to observe the bus you're
desperately trying to catch instead of
continuing the process of desperately
trying to catch it the leg hiker looks
to our camera and i am unreasonably
annoyed by it
tough look for vision here the memorial
wall only including tony and natasha is
pretty harsh don't let wanda see it she
might kidnap your entire town and force
you into slave labor for her own
fantasies only to be redeemed because
she maybe learned her lesson for a few
seconds before a movie needed her to be
super evil again and we wouldn't want
something like that to happen kamala's
phone goes off and says motion detected
and then it shows us the dining room
where her parents already are how is
that thing not going off every few
seconds look show if you just needed to
remind us that kamal is here without her
parents permission you could have just
had her check the camera without the
notification like a normal creepy
teenager who has cameras set up to spy
on their parents people who don't
realize there are flashes on when it
doesn't need to be kamala sets her
helmet down so the badass gloves touch
the disgusting bathroom floor who does
that people who need an excuse to lose
them for a plot point that's
marvel who competition it is not what
are you wearing
dumb red carpet questions
[Applause]
oh sure bruno has been into kamala in
this whole process this entire time but
just at the moment magic stuff happens
he's all like i think i'll stare at the
people on the stage nonstop now so the
audience will believe that this means
i'm not seeing this and that will stand
in for the rest of this massive crowd
who also is somehow not noticing this
yep that's exactly what unsure and
nervous humans do they go directly to
the center of the stage and walk to the
very front it's basic psychology look it
up i'd like to make it clear that this
not spherical ant-man noggin will land
in water with the antenna parts facing
forward making it difficult to roll and
almost zero forward momentum and yet
somehow we'll roll a hundred feet
through this warehouse crashing into
tables demolishing a giant brick wall
and still having enough force left to
give head to a load-bearing support beam
physic much movie
zoe survives this i bet you'll be a
little thor tomorrow i'm sorry just
please continue watching to the end
anyway it appears as though our heroes
are panic pedaling home after a
disturbing event one would think they
would ditch the light up
attention-grabbing costumes to seem less
suspicious but no maybe the first
indicator that kamal has been busted is
that her parents closed the [ __ ]
window she left open
[Music]
where have you been how has kamala not
check the camera i know she was
preoccupied at the event but she
couldn't have taken a second on the bike
ride home to see how things were going
at the home front or do you want to be
some you know this cosmic
head in the clouds person she asks while
standing in a room that is a vibrant
shrine to a cosmic woman flying
headfirst through the clouds you did 17
of these earlier we do not need another
one bring her in at this point i'm just
going to send a post-credit scene in a
marvel production cliche and move on two
basketballs are not enough to call this
scene out for over basketballing but it
is two too many basketballs for a high
school hallway without the accompanying
teacher yelling for them to put those in
a locker i wonder if now that kamal is
all confident and stuff she'll realize
that she can break this pattern of
perfectly timed high school hallway
[ __ ] by simply arriving a minute
earlier or two minutes later what makes
you think you have ammo powers because
we're about charming and we look a lot
younger than we are marvel thinks that
its introduction of the multiverse makes
it okay to steal jokes from our universe
about paul rudd's abnormal and
completely unfair genetics i heard zoe's
follower count like quadruple this
weekend and now we enter the opposite
side of the hallway where the tunnel of
exposition is already in progress this
qr code works yes i'm giving that a sin
because it leads us to a site where
marvel teases free content while also
dangling in front of us another paid
subscription service which i'm probably
signing up for because i'm absolutely
loving the show so the sin is me being
incapable of not giving my money to
marvel and disney being incapable of not
taking it and then all of a sudden there
was all this screaming and i was thrown
to the ground how how do you forget that
you were slammed by thor's hammer how do
you forget that also you know all those
times in life where you stand shoulder
to shoulder with your friends for a
protracted period of time so everyone
has to turn their necks 90 degrees to
engage in the conversation and the
camera can film everyone from the same
angle yeah neither do i so who was it uh
night light show is leaning hard into
its portrayal of superheroes as
celebrities in this reality so it stands
to reason that kamal is an up-and-coming
star what doesn't make sense is that zoe
would feel the need to make up this name
on the spot that would be like us naming
courtney cox nightlight when we saw her
for the first time in cocoon the return
i don't know guys it's hard for me to
take scenes like this seriously when
there are people positioned behind zoe
who are only able to stare directly at
the back of her head as if that is
somehow normal i see we're sticking with
the 17 logos theme in episode 2 which
means i suddenly feel obligated to send
this again but i don't like being
obligated to sin so this sin is for the
pressure to sin and my determination to
break free by sending it anyway which
somehow brings me a sense of control
therapy for the win i'm going to point
out that if the school has any budget
issues they might want to consider
turning unneeded lights off in unused
parts of the building like this one
i guess we wouldn't truly be backstage
in a high school theater if this random
assortment of easily toppled items
wasn't set up and ready to fall at the
slightest nudge featuring this beautiful
mural by b-mike would have earned this
show a sin off or not for the fact that
it's in atlanta and not jersey city okay
no super strength all i got is this
being mildly dissatisfied with just one
superpower so it looks like your power
isn't coming from the bank show wants
you to know that you'll do none of this
and more on your microsoft surface does
this look like some kind of writing
looks like arabic or
urdu i don't know if only the teenage
smart guy who somehow managed to scan
your body and interpret all sorts of
graphs on a tablet could also take a
photo of this writing and feed it into a
piece of technology that would
immediately google translate it again
the show says new jersey when the
skyline says georgia you have to let me
go
as the saying goes pride comes before
the fall from an inconsequential height
that you concealed with a deceiving
camera angle to artificially create
tension despite the fact that we all
know you're not gonna harm the main
character in any meaningful way in the
second episode of the series
also super good thing that not one
person is looking through all these
windows at the highly suspect
shenanigans happening in broad daylight
beating pipes does not make water come
out faster beating pipes makes it worse
when you're so brand loyal that you feel
the need to correct your elders in the
masjid but still can't be bothered to
use the entire name of said brand
you really gotta fix this place
uh
no you mean they gotta fix our section
of this place it's clear the scene is
trying to make a point about unequal
distribution of resources but audio
feedback is loud terrible and should be
heard all throughout this room not just
in one section sisters no talking during
the lecture please because of course our
favorites get in trouble for whispering
even though the selfie sisters were so
loud just a moment ago selective hearing
that drives the plot is selective and
the mosque thief has struck again
writers think i won't immediately become
more interested in the case of the shoe
thief than i am in the main plot that is
the 22nd pair of shoes that have been
stolen so go with me here maybe stop
wearing expensive desirable shoes to a
place where people keep stealing them
thanks for coming miguel's hovering who
the [ __ ] is miguel what's up you want
some is there alcohol in that
no it's just orange juice who the [ __ ]
is this kid and why is he offering
random people his orange juice and why
is kamal accepting his orange juice and
why does the scene feel like a
meaningful lesson about not trusting
drinks from strangers wrapped in a
contrived coming-of-age trope and why do
i feel like adding a sin even though i
agree with the message
throw my [ __ ] i was gonna sin the
attractive character sexually emerges
from water cliche but i'm gonna pivot to
the starstruck character as standing on
clothing that is needed by waterlogged
hottie cliche because it's just so
annoying when it happens
did did she just pull a drink out of the
freezer i think she just pulled a drink
out of a freezer this is one of the most
clever ways i've seen texting visualized
on screen it reminds me of just how well
this show makes use of effects like this
to tell kamala's story and give her
world a fun and youthful aesthetic
kamala agrees to driving lessons without
checking with her parents first is that
allowed kids are terrifying spend six
weeks on ancient rome in ancient greece
but six minutes on ancient persia and
byzantium nakia would be the marvelous
miss marvel at world history sins hey
kika are you feeling all right kamala
can't stop glowing which i fail to see
the issue with but the show presents it
as a problem that can't be solved
without first confirming that she's
tried to take the bengal off or that she
even still has it on for that matter i
know how weird your mom can get about
tampons tampons oh come on it's not like
people believe they get lost in your
bloodstream or something
wait they did okay well it's not like
some people believe you lose your
virginity to them or something
oh they do fine at least we all know
they're made from cotton candy
wait what okay well then this sin is for
ridiculous misunderstandings about
tampons
i mean she does have another hand if she
wanted to carry on the cycle ruse and
reach for it de-stress after school best
thing you can do
drive in jersey city show wants me to
believe that it believes there are roads
in the tri-state area designed in any
way to help someone de-stress without
having a full-on panic attack maybe
someday you'll feel like jersey's your
home jersey
this is komron
he's our cousin this works the british
left us with a mess my exact statement
after eating lunch with ian somehow
makes it into the script hey there's a
story about muniba's family that i
quickly need to talk about because it's
important to the plot so stand by while
i expose it a little for the audience
i wait for the post every day yeah i'll
get on that boldface lying to your
elders but no i've spoken too much
already no no i'm not going to talk
about this at all
is someone who once received an electric
massager from their grandparents i'm
aware that certain presents should never
be acknowledged or discussed but nani
refusing to talk about the family
heirloom she just gifted kamala seems
more about drawing out the story and
less about things people actually do
i don't have a mango man in the scene
something wrong the voices on the phone
could be heard in the hallway aways from
the door mr khan bangs on the door when
he opens it he believes that kamala is
just asleep are the men in the show just
dumb
after that we will mobilize these sunday
school teachers help infiltrate the
institute fine don't explain what
incriminating evidence has given the
teachers leverage over the insta click
but at least tell me why are these teens
always ordering groceries
technically the reverts but to do that
you have to make it past the mini
what have they been sworn to protect the
reverts for some reason even then it
looks like they're really into running
around a bunch so getting past them is
probably just a matter of waiting until
they're out of your way the illuminantes
i'll talk to them i mean sure go
directly to the aunties but wasn't the
whole point of the last scene to go to
specific groups first to get a greater
chance at the aunties and if not then
why show us the previous progression of
the political plan at all i have to go
after my white whale character uses
everyone's favorite literary reference
for something difficult cliche as nikia
presses for a vote i'm reminded that too
many people use the political knuckle
pointing gesture thing it's distracting
and i'm so focused on it that i can't
even hear anything important being said
oh she's talking about women's rights oh
no worries we don't have to worry about
anything changing there right right i'm
not sure where to get anything on this
played in that is a [ __ ] sin because
it looks delicious
is this about the party that's a strange
question to ask when the first question
should be where are my parents i heard
she killed a man
dead uh yes killing one does mean they
are dead i never understand why anyone
says kill the man dead as if there are
other options not figuring out what
filter setting to use prior to selfieing
yourself out a window so that the
writers could cook up a scenario
requiring our resident hero to intervene
in summation even as a narrative device
the sin here is still kids how did
anyone get this shot at eye level as
kamala did a ridiculous three-point
superhero landing
given the way he lands on each of these
things as he blinks his way to the
ground it makes sense if he said my face
my back my ribs or even my ass but my
ankle how the [ __ ] did that happen show
wants us to believe that no one here not
even scowls mcgee saw komron zoom in
with his uncle's whip pick up kamala and
speed away i'd like you to be my mom
damn comrade you've only been on one
date i found the bangle should we be
concerned it's on a several faria would
be a good guy that actually turns out to
be a bad guy at tv since also should we
be concerned that we're just freely
touching the blue severed arm without
thinking of the cooties that are
undoubtedly mating on the skin yes yes
we should so where's the other one i
told you the british have probably
looted this place twice over by now but
since the audience wasn't here for that
i'm gonna tell you again also the
british then one will have to do what is
she basing that on is she happy for
whatever she's doing to only work 50 of
the time or only at 50 of the power i'm
not pretending to know how this thing
works but i really wouldn't want to risk
only half of me being teleported across
dimensions
how
how does one set stone a flame did you
see that nope because once again when
the bangle is activated no one is
looking you go that way
characters split up for reasons even
though they likely don't have to cliche
we're not here by choice we were exiled
and that is not at all a massive warning
sign in any way for some reason don't
mind him
we've been around for a hundred years
and he picks the stupidest parts of
humanity to be obsessed with shut your
mouth pop rocks are explosive particles
of oral and oral joy and i will not hear
otherwise paul decorations and bowls
baffle me are they reminders of when
people had yarn balls at the ready for
knitting or crochet are they cat taunts
why take up this much space for a bowl
of [ __ ] balls but i know
that you've inherited greatness and with
greatness comes great
wait and now you must finish what she
started nope she does not generational
expectations can go to hell in a
shocking turn of events miss marvel has
veered from the 17 logo pattern of the
first two episodes to a baffling 19. why
why not have 18 last episode and 20 next
episode did no one plan this did no one
think that someone would go frame by
frame counting every single image does
no one know who we are anymore
see there's like
ghost stories and then there's gin
stories and the gin stories are so much
worse because they're real and yet still
no alarm bells are ringing that these
people that just poofed into kamala's
life out of nowhere may not be on the up
and up also they need my help which
means i need your help boldly admitting
that you are flat out using your friend
do you know anything about
interdimensional travel off the top of
your head i get that this is a
deliberately ridiculous request to get a
laugh but does she honestly expect
actually no that reminds me of a paper i
read what the [ __ ] he actually does
serious because your person of interest
is enhanced or because she was spot at a
mosque man i hate to imagine how often
incidents similar to this have happened
in the last 20 years i'm willing to bet
it's all too often and i'm glad the
show's putting it front and center
watching tick tock on your computer
instead of your phone also tick tock
all these people your family has this
not been explained to you before today
is anyone asking how bruno had a perfect
model of kamala's face with which to
create this mask i just realized that
the lighting of the store is perfect for
dramatic tension but horrible for actual
shopping hey listen i can help you with
this mr khan will somehow spot the word
jinn from this very casual glance which
will result in him ex-posit
translationing the whole damn thing so
that everyone in the back row is brought
up to date also what is up with the shot
why does it look like we're hiding
inside the shelf spying on mr khan and
bruno or am i not supposed to talk about
that
a highly specific piece of lore about a
highly specific group of people that
will specifically assist this scene
becoming highly convenient for the plot
cheer up
come on yeah kill that emotion the
timing isn't right when someone else
needs attention for a greater and more
important event than your breakdown
don't be overtaken when you can clamp a
lid on that so tight it will never leak
out through the form of losers tears
excuse me show there have been inventive
texting visuals overlaid over bed
spreads neon signs and lights on the
ceiling where's the ingenuity now why
aren't the characters on the wall
bursting to life and spelling out this
conversation you set the standard why
allow this text to be boring tricking me
into thinking this qr code was a
possible teaser for a new monument
valley when in fact it is yet another
attempt to get me to sign up for
something that costs money after seven
days
weddings a man has one fundamental
choice in life
to live a life
in fear
or love mr khan then goes on to also
mention that he chooses
faith
courage which seems like more than one
fundamental choice to me and to make
things more confusing he adds man who
chooses family is never alone so now our
fundamental singular choices of love or
fear which was an oversimplification
meant to make things easier for amir has
instantly become more complicated with
faith courage and family now on the
table never have i seen a couple so
certain of their love
as they are of themselves and everyone
else in the room who was married by this
man takes a long look at their marriage
partner and wonders if this is yet
another sign that they shouldn't have
married so soon we're going to make her
help us
i'm not asking anymore my goodness najma
goes all in on the evil reveal very
quickly there's still a good chance that
kamala will help them and after a
hundred years of waiting what's the rush
now exposing yourself now is far riskier
and if you don't believe me najma just
skip ahead to the end of the episode
this extremely wholesome celebration is
beautiful but still goes on for all that
did i not mention i hate weddings
sometime i don't mind a great dance
scene in a show especially ones that are
so filled with smiles and vibrancy but i
do mind all the shots to the audience's
reaction why cut away to strangers to
prove that everyone's having a good time
show me the cast dancing or show me
nothing at all you're not safe none of
you are safe kamala they're coming after
you instead of telling kamala exactly
what's going on komron pronoun games so
hard that even though i've seen the
build-up to this i still have no idea
what or who he's talking about everyone
needs to get out of here right now you'd
think the room that has the most fire in
the building would also have the most
fire alarms but clearly not because as
the rest of the building evacuates these
cooks continue about their evening i
hope they get tipped well is everything
all right inside they're not letting us
back in yes that's generally how fires
work even the unconfirmed ones wasting
cake it would appear that the battle
strategy of attacking one at a time and
ignoring any possible flanking maneuvers
afforded by having multiple people on
your side is a multi-dimensional
constant
hang on if najma can just use that
dagger spear to smash the marvelous
stepping stones why doesn't she use it
to break through the light shield that
kamala puts up it's made of the same
right
this is some physics-defying [ __ ]
even for marvel the only way kamala
escapes from the tablecloth unseen is if
the hench people somehow suffered from
temporary blindness or the bengal
decided to function as a plot teleporter
instead of plot armor for a few seconds
the magical beings from another
dimension quickly ditched their cool
signature weaponry for good old
fisticuffs because that's clearly more
entertaining to watch once again several
people are approaching kamala who
suddenly showed no interest in watching
her depart despite her bright colors and
shimmery superpowers also just because
kamal and najma see a distracting
ethereal train coming out of the sky
does not mean the rest of the gen
wouldn't notice the dodc entering the
building and approaching them for an
ambush earlier we saw nakia lee for no
apparent reason and now she inexplicably
turns up here just in time to see kamala
use her powers and i need to know why we
aren't focusing on her story and how she
got her powers of telepathy and or
perfect timing can you tell us what
exactly happened
i can't your 16 year old daughter just
ruined your son's wedding you saw her
with a strange group of adults that now
have been arrested and you're gonna
accept i just can't as a reason for why
she won't explain any of this to you
this has gone way beyond sneaking off at
night without permission she could be
and is in serious danger and you're just
sitting her off to bed with no supper
what is going on here we're four
episodes in and you still can't get it
right disney it's miss marvel jeez first
time for pakistan stop normalizing
[ __ ] strangers that insist on talking
to you on flights what makes you say
that you're gripping that stuffed animal
pretty tight this could just as easily
mean she's afraid of flying missing her
friends or that the sloth is possessed
by an ancient demon from a forgotten
realm that if unleashed will devour the
souls of the pure through their eyeballs
unless kamala maintains a very specific
grip around its slothy abdomen you don't
know holding your heart warming family
reunion in the middle of the [ __ ]
arrival gate at an incredibly busy
airport take your happiness where it
isn't in the way
oopsie remember that time i was hanging
out of the car window and that guy had
to swerve out of the way and ended up
breaking both of his legs as he flew out
of control into that poor man's small
business
yeah good times
[Music]
this one no silly that's the fabled room
of expositioning could you tell by the
clearly vague instructions that led you
here
your cousins are waiting for you no your
cousins have been rudely allowed to
stroll into your bedroom so they can
watch while you're sleeping you can
bring your flying teddy bear
oh i'm so sorry i'm late it's okay we
know it's because you're in a tv show
and therefore had no choice but to
arrive late because there's literally no
other recorded way to start a
conversation in a tv show or movie also
almost a quarter of this episode is
meeting family members man as wholesome
as that is i don't think it's the best
use of the show's time isn't there some
sort of threat to the fabric of reality
going on why is kamala acting like she
isn't being chased down by an evil group
of ancient gen it's yours if you tell me
the direction to the train station we've
seen in other scenes that kamala has a
cell phone that's still functioning in
pakistan so why don't you just pull up a
google maps instead of giving this guy
some money for confusing directions one
more left and then
right little little bit right okay this
despite kamala looking clearly confused
and borderline panicked works
where did kamala go
graffiti artists can go with any avenger
for their art piece and they choose
[ __ ] ant-man even scott lang wouldn't
choose ant-man at this point chemo
thinks that kamala is a clandestine so
he either deliberately missed because he
likes drama or he somehow managed to
miss an unprepared enemy while they had
their back turned not sure what's worse
those glasses you tied on or that mask
says the individual wearing a mask do
all my family can have superpowers well
how do you know i'm not canadian kamala
would be deadpool at tv sins where'd you
learn to jump like that ninja turtles
where did you learn yours huh donkey
kong where'd you learn to deliver those
lame insults the
lame
insult store
who are you
what are you you're not a clandestine
you know about them how did you get it
from aisha answering so many questions
with so many other questions have these
kids never been told how to conversation
come with me if you want to live what
just kidding i've always wanted to say
that kimo here immediately goes from
trying to kill kamala because he thinks
she's a clandestine to joking around and
taking her to his secret base for no
apparent reason other than she seems
confused there's someone you need to
meet you'd better come take a look at
this person i need you to meet cliche
furnishing your secret hideout with a
glass ceiling that can be conveniently
broken into by your enemies not that
something like that would ever happen
wait what this was kamala all along for
hundreds of years that scarf has
protected the identity of warriors
willing to take on the mantle of the red
dagger assuming they aren't easily
identifiable by their ears eyes hair
fingerprints more dna of any sort it's
connected to a world but hid
behind the wheel of mood that separates
our world from us i mean it's a very
pretty map but does it do anything else
like is it just pulled out for
expositional purposes how often are they
bringing in strangers and telling them
about the nord dimension that it
requires this fancy demo do you know
what it says
it says what you seek is seeking you oh
what in case you confused it with the
department of disastrous colons i have
so many questions about what the [ __ ]
just happened here it looks like najma
has had a dagger in her hand all along
so how did the guards not see it and why
the [ __ ] has she waited until now to use
it i swear marvel edits this stuff so
quickly i'm sure they're just hoping
everyone will be so suddenly befuddled
that they don't even question anything
well that's my secret marvel i'm always
befuddled everyone call her sloth
take the baby
fame
you shall pay for this dignity
oh sure whenever i start playing guitar
around the campfire everyone suddenly
has plans they forgot about and hair
they have to wash but when suave jones
here starts strumming away the entire
group is captivated
suave jones tell me why is all this such
a mess huh
and what are all these newspapers and
magazines kids
complaining to the person giving you a
free massage maybe it is time for you to
start considering coming to live with us
in america and maybe it's time for us to
consider a skip your humanity links you
to the matter of this world
it makes your abilities unique as long
as your definition of unique only
extends to big fists and stepping stones
am i a dagger now premature celebration
surprise surprise indeed how the hell
they get here so fast it is at least an
18 hour flight from new jersey to
karachi and cabal has only been here two
maybe three days so the clandestines
managed to break out of the dodc figure
out kamala was in pakistan fly there and
figure out where this top secret red
dagger base was in i demand to know who
gave them the script this completely
unflinching couple who pays zero
attention to the three people sprinting
past them as they enjoy their meal why
is she putting on the mask now why is
this mask
[Music]
i realize the clandestines would be
experienced and talented enough to pull
off a truck jacking but how is the
driver just landing to where he was
thrown as the truck is passing by that
wouldn't require the ability to take the
driver out of the truck while i was
still moving and someone immediately in
the vicinity of the gas pedal and
steering wheel to keep it moving on
course and that's all the bullsh
do something
i can't do anything come on man what do
you want from her it's not like she has
some sort of bracelet that can tap into
a vast energy source from a parallel
dimension with the ability to create
matter at will sheesh
conveniently broken down family is very
convenient or inconvenient i mean it's
obviously inconvenient for them but it's
a very convenient obstacle for look i'm
just saying this is some [ __ ]
manufactured attention get yourself to
safety i'll lead them off i'm amazed
even one of the clandestines chose to
follow him let alone their leader najma
they're just after the bracelet right
why do they give a [ __ ] about catching
waleed okay
driving on the opposite side of the road
on stick you said opposite side of the
road instead of wrong side of the road
it's okay kamala we all make mistakes
honestly i don't even have the mental
fortitude to keep up with this chase but
i can confidently say that this is some
high grade bs that almost everyone
managed to end up on this street at this
exact time including and especially this
sudden deus ex kamalakana right here
we have to go and let's just leave the
truck behind because it would have only
gotten us to wherever we needed to go
faster being on foot increases our
chances of getting caught so let's go
that route pretty sure that label should
read convenient instead of caution we
have to help it it's too late when is it
with characters giving up so quickly on
their mentors kimo didn't even have time
to check a pulse that is not his call to
make i'm sure something cool is
happening right now so here are 10 extra
sins for not showing it to us and
instead opting to offend my eyes with a
billion impossible to follow cuts and
whooshes thanks marvel again
cool are we going to get some kind of
explosion of nor magic that rips a hole
in reality that will expose kamala to an
alternate dimension where everyone is
made of paint or rocks and wait are we
in the past
at the stroke of the midnight hour is
marvel aeration with those words on the
eve of august 15 1947. i love me some
historical fiction so i was very excited
when i saw this intro shift to sepia and
this film reel got queued up especially
since this is a place in time i know
little to nothing about but then i
realized it wasn't one of the characters
watching this archival footage it was
just me marvel's tricked me into this
expositional history class and all my
instincts from childhood tell me i
should resist it by kicking and sinning
scene opens on the feet of someone
running fetish i i mean cliche
bringing a knife to a gunfight i mean it
ends up working out but doesn't make it
any less of a sin my hands are tied
the sin as always is the british
poking someone with your stick without
explicit consent touch me and i'll break
your neck
well you mean this one assange laughs
this off because one of his legs isn't
very good but regardless it'd still be
incredibly painful to have it broken and
it's not like she specified which leg
she'd even be breaking also villagers
are now speaking in english to each
other even though in the previous scene
they were not no human alive can resist
the smell of a fresh fried paratha
paratha boasting barathasting
boseparathing
also this works do you know when i saw
you out there
it reminded me of my favorite poem i
can't hear whether or not he says poem
or poet but the subtitles of my version
say favorite poem while hassan goes on
to describe two different quotes by the
same poet so whether it's the fault of
the person who said the words or the
person who transcribed them here's a sin
aisha she who lives a beautiful man tv
shows and movies always act like knowing
the meaning of someone's name is second
nature well i don't know the exact
percentage of people that memorize what
every name means in their language i
feel safe in saying it's less than one
percent furthermore tv shows and movies
treat this particular skill as if it's
romantic or cute where it's actually
creepy as hell aisha should be running
now because it's 50 50 or whether or not
hassan is a serial killer
aisha is not singing me a lullaby in
this
[Music]
sweeps scene the country the prime
minister urges india's citizens to
remain calm by saying
that wasn't clever editing by us these
lines just hilariously line up on their
own and making jokes out of your
dialogue is supposed to be my job of
course i do but i hit the bangle for
safekeeping you have until sundown
tomorrow this is one of the most
uncomfortable conversations i've ever
seen and each character is telegraphing
super hard how their intentions do not
match what they're actually saying it's
so obvious that i have no idea why
either of them is attempting a ruse and
it's surprising that this doesn't
immediately break down into a brawl in
which all of hassan's roses get trampled
oh look at that another object imbued
with mystical powers glows purple in a
marvel property probably all connected
or some right she knew i was running
from something
but she never never pushed because i
didn't care and you're hot or uh i mean
the didn't care thing that's what i
meant i'll find it if it's the last
thing i do sure we all knew aisha was
going to die or at least disappear
because kamala's father prophesied it at
the dinner table in episode two but
still finding the bengal probably could
have been the first or maybe even second
thing you did if you hadn't killed the
person who knows where it is and where
it's going you have
everything that should be except for a
more precise explanation of how i got
here and what i'm supposed to be doing
now that i'm here but sure i'll take
this picture and hope for the best
you're supposed to save nani like the
story she's okay
because you are here cho tries to
downplay it but it pretty much just
pulled it back to the future by creating
a situation where kamala has to help her
grandmother get to the train in order to
ensure her own existence she just died
from a pretty severe stab wound and yet
there's not an ounce of blood to be seen
just saying this is one of many ways
modern media is giving our kids
unrealistic expectations
for as simple a premise as it is a lost
child continues to be one of the
scariest things one can see on screen
i'm a bit resentful of the writers for
using this against my emotions
how exactly is this more effective than
carrying her grandmother back to hassan
the crowd of people is still in the way
it'd be one thing if she formed these
things up and over the crowd but she's
putting them at max one to two feet off
of the ground all right i get that
everybody here probably has bigger
concerns at the moment but kamala using
her powers seemed to be a pretty big
deal to everyone in her time period now
i'm not expecting everyone to start
posting about it on social media but i'm
sure at least a few of these people
would be like what the [ __ ] is this
i see the writers have decided the
biggest threat to kamal's powers will be
slight bumps and distractions
kamala doesn't acknowledge how this time
loop nonsense of traveling from the
future to create your own past can
really with your concept of free will
this line was not preceded by if my
train goes off the track she's not
picking up the phone
i mean she's still not home i'm doubling
the previous sin because now my
neighbor's just showing off you know
magnum got lost once i had him microchip
okay ami magnum is a dog kamala's
grandmother has been extremely generous
and wise up to this point so i'm not
buying for a second she would think this
magnum story was in any way relatable to
what kamala's mom is going through if
kamala's phone is on your family plan
you can just log into your account and
use the find my phone feature to see
where she is explaining things to old
people in a condescending manner because
technology is just so easy for you
having grown up with it all your lives
with cell phones and handheld computers
listen your parents managed to learn and
unlearn some of the most unintuitive
computer systems the world has ever
known and they did it well before they
decided to tell everyone you were not a
mistake so cut them some slack and
explain things with a little bit of
patience you mac wielding [ __ ] um
kids
the sin is kids this episode raiders of
the lost ark so fast i think i got
whiplash and don't forget that in the
latin alphabet jehovah begins with an i
in case that information becomes useful
to you when you're on your last crusade
this is as good as any time to ask does
comron have a father i feel like he may
be a curiously absent character i hope
najma reveals that oh never mind
this works
i don't know but i like to think
[Music]
two people fell in love skip frank this
is either an attempt to convey the bruno
views comron as a threat or the writer's
using the old jump scare equals bad
person or bad motives trick i'm sending
it as the latter because i'm a betting
man and that seems like the direction
this is all going
of damage control my ass going with a
blanket statement about upsetting scenes
that might occur but not giving any
specifics as to who it might upset
thereby providing little more
information than saying nothing at all
what happens when the wrong people
the
get
powers
kids agent barry agent barry may be the
most complex character in the series he
takes agent ever to task on a comment
that comes off as racist and then when
he finds out she's talking about kids he
proposes enhanced rounds as a solution
and has to be told i want this kid taken
alive the sin is not digging further
into this man's decision-making process
damage control could be a penn station
so we're gonna transfer at the next stop
and head upstate okay bruno assumes that
in all of the tri-state area damage
control has focused its entire search on
just one transportation hub how can he
be so sure they won't already be at the
next stop and at pretty much every
station that leads out of the city as
bruno and comrade make their way from
car to car on the subway we can see
these two completely different windows
have very similar graffiti so similar
i'm calling someone out for plagiarism
comron somehow neither kills nor hurts
anyone in the subway car with his
spontaneous nora missions oh my god
i had no idea
kids i i mean older siblings that insist
on perpetuating the same relationship
dynamic that existed when you were kids
in classic khan gossip train whether it
be gossip trains or just gossip in
general gossip is a sin although does
that mean i'm gossiping about how gossip
is a sin did i just break the fourth sin
wall in this video did save by the bell
the college years really only last one
season i need to know
speak up speakers because just vape
convenience this old people use
technology wrong bit that everyone here
seems in on goes on long enough to
wonder if even the characters in marvel
properties are feeling over saturated
with the ever expanding amount of
superhero content being made so much so
that they'd rather talk about use of
cell phone habits instead of kamala
being a freaking superhero
please pick up
you're done writers undermine all the
urgency by having kamala be pretty
quickly distracted by this
heart-to-heart suit reveal this qr code
started off as a fun little easter egg
in previous episodes but now i'm
beginning to worry that it's going to be
spun off into its own series
yeah it's not like her best friend could
be a burnt corpse at this point or need
her help might as well have an
unnecessary moment where she stops at a
red light for comedic effect also unless
this is a low-key acknowledgement of
spider-man there's no other sky traffic
she would need to stop for and really no
need to stop for spider-man either you
know because of his tingle when the
coast is clear you guys head to the high
school and i'll call kamala
why would we go to high school because
the only place guaranteed to be empty on
a saturday unless there's a sporting
event saturday detention a local event
being held at the high school or the
janitorial staff gets a lot of their
work done on saturday but other than
those things and probably 10 or 20 more
yeah it could be empty presumably male
16 to 25 pakistani or arab but you are
describing practically everyone here she
is not
i don't have time for chronic quotes
excuse me
actually that was abraham lincoln boom
you've been lincoln trust me you don't
want a felony on your high school
transcript that would be weird yes but
you don't know that for sure i wanted
braces in high school till i actually
had them what can i say teens are weird
did you hear that
i'm a boyfriend
and you're both witnesses why is miguel
did nokia even need a person in the
closet to keep this ruse going this long
this room might as well have been filled
with rasheed's yummy yummy chocolate
chip cookies you need a disguise okay
marvel you're very funny and i must
admit that i enjoyed this
self-referential poke and how often your
production team thinks a baseball cap
would in any way be a sufficient
disguise but in this case the joke here
feels a bit like a hat on a hat what are
you guys wearing
what are you wearing the more important
question is how did kamala know this is
where she would find bruno and comrade
and if your answer is that nokia had
already called her then i will ask you
where on that costume kamal is keeping a
cell phone i feel like i'm being crushed
from the inside out my screams from when
i was trying to take a picture at my
local theater in 2015 and the heavier
than it looked pixar stand up fell on
top of me somehow make their way into
this episode i really need to get him
out of town i know someone who can get
him out well that was so easily resolved
and i'm a bit confused is why we're
using up run time on this call instead
of putting it to good use with more
glowy pad jumping they tried to trick me
into giving you up zoe x mocking on
their way into the group for
reasons this is the plan is the plan to
dedicate a lot of time to detail
drawings that ultimately cut into what
the show is trying to sell is a limited
time to set up the plan because that's
pretty much what's going on here and the
only reason it doesn't impact the show
in any way has to do with the writers
deciding that time has no meaning here
how did you get in here bathroom window
i went to school here too because
knowing how to open an unlocked window
and crawl through it proves you were at
this location on a daily basis for four
years superiors don't need chaperones
take it up with her guys clock's ticking
i appreciate comrade coming in to assist
with this sin but still the show has
time for this if the drawing of your
hoodie needs to also be labeled then
maybe just skip the drawings and go with
a list also you're in a defensive
position and not actively targeting the
dodc agents and feds well at least most
of you won't be just remember when they
all get caught later then instead of
making better preparations our resident
technical expert chose to [ __ ] around
with his skeleton the thing you're
supposed to break the glass with is
right there on the side of the box the
entire time i have no idea if this was
supposed to be funny or just make me
angry clarity on either side would have
been fine you and i can't grab as many
balls as you can this sin is for the
high school versions of you and me that
are laughing exceedingly long at this
statement and the real plan
zoe okay so i guess using zoe's social
media presence in this plan does make
all of the sense but i'd also like to
reaffirm that her conveniently being at
the school so she could be part of this
makes no sense so you mean to tell me
you knew kamal had powers and you didn't
say anything zoe may not have said
anything but she did force us to listen
to everyone refer to kamala as night
light for six episodes do you even like
british bake off no no one genuinely
likes british bake off amir and i'm
positive everyone in the youtube
comments will back me up on this
no
not zuzu not like this as silly as the
next four minutes of home alone-esque
hi-jinx are and the idea that all these
highly trained damage control soldiers
get outwitted by a bunch of kids and one
random adult is a little insane i gotta
admit it's also pretty fun to watch with
that being said all of these highly
trained damage control soldiers get
outwitted by a bunch of kids and one
random adult my hands are tied people
go but he can multiply now multiple man
shadowing just with me well just excuse
me while i skip along some glowing lily
pads to get up and over this scene
hey
guys come dance with me
[Music]
you know you like these moves aside from
bruno's disturbing lack of rhythm i
don't recall this stance being a part of
this well-illustrated plan all it would
have taken was one shot from one of
these shockwave rifles to end this
softball nonsense but luckily the dodc
trains their agents to blindly run
around corners what happened to my mom
comrade figures out something has
happened to his mother from nothing more
than kamala's desire to get help from
the red daggers instead of najma and his
amazing skills of intuition are never
used again in the series
i guess this soldier must have attended
school here as well since he's familiar
with the bathroom window entrance i
wonder if he was in the same class as
amir inside the school the soldiers were
firing at the kids just because they're
running away from them but outside they
just let komron get all juiced up
without firing one shot comrade will now
be a villain for the next six minutes
completely undermining the whole hat
situation with him and bruno earlier
that moment when all the supporting
characters try to make us believe that
our hero might not win this one
deciding to start giving your powers
names in the middle of a fight between
this and the commitment to only
hand-drawn plans i'm beginning to
question kamala's priorities
kamala was either very certain all the
agents would move out of the way at the
last second or she was very prepared to
kill a bunch of people right here
bringing a gun to a glowy light crystal
with ill-defined powers fight everyone
celebrates not being crushed to death by
cheering
instead of leaving the area so as not to
be almost crushed to death again as much
fun as the show can be diva is a
terrible and one-note villain i don't
even think tyler hayward would have just
started opening fire at children
especially not with a viewing audience
kamal running crew survives this because
the luck of not being killed instantly
when the glowing rocks hit the van was
only surpassed by the luck of these
things deciding to suddenly start
expanding in a much slower rate and her
last moment she sent everything she had
to protect you that's what happened i'm
glad they cleared it up for me but this
exposition would have been more helpful
in the previous episode it would have
gotten us in there too just for being
exposition but i would have appreciated
it more get to the harbor
i'll buy you time did kamala drop a
detailed map of jersey city subsystems
that i'm unaware of how did she know
what would be under the ground here and
why does she just assume that comron
will know how to get to the harbor
through this random hole she's created
in the ground and why is comrade so
confident in his ability to do this that
he slides right down into the ground
with no further questions
are you okay that was amazing i'm not
sure kamala needs this mask since her
parents are clearly going to do a [ __ ]
job of keeping her identity secret
kapow
kablam
are the best new jersey city lying or
shameless self-promotion take your pick
i share the same name as carol freaking
danvers i don't know who that is he
doesn't how is that even possible
outside of the fact that she helped save
the world his daughter's images of carol
plastered all over a room yusuf has
never once asked hey what's the name of
that lady on your wall but you sure are
and always have been
our own little
miss marvel roll commercials is what we
say here on tv sins but i might have to
start making an exception for marvel in
their penchant for surprisingly long
credits on a tv show i for one think
that it looks much better on the streets
of jersey city thinking anything looks
better in new jersey kamala there's
something different in your genes like a
mutation threatening us with x-men
content instead of just giving us a
moment to be content with the story we
just finished whatever it is it's just
going to be another label marvel
sounding completely uninterested in
delivering the x-men content it just
threatened us with
marvel forces marvel's captain marvel
into marvel's miss marvel to prep for
marvel's the marvels because
marvel
have you tried
not being a mutant who is that girl i
see sorry that's the lion king but the
point still stands i could like wear
cakes
there's a scientific study that shows
that if you stand like this in superhero
pose you will not only feel more
confident you will perform measurably
better that's the plan got it i'm not
sure this plan will work how likely is
it i'm gonna find it there when i get
back oh i'd say you have a point zero
zero zero one percent chance so you're
telling me there's a chance
did you ever have the feeling you was
being
watched
what goes up must come down wait what
makes you think you have mm powers i ate
six muffins downstairs a while ago and
my cholesterol level is 305. this girl
shows up breaks into my house takes the
lantern blasts me
and suddenly she's best friends with
that
saying she's a superhero's daughter
and we're just supposed to believe it
all without question
now it comes to it i don't feel like
partying with it it's mine i found it it
came to me rudolph please could you tone
it down a bit that nose that beautiful
wonderful nose
one
very cute
and chanel you're in desperate need of
chanel hello
what'd you do jump ship
what
what's with the life preserve
remember the time you were working with
um what was the name hot spot topic of
course freaking hot topic that explains
everything how do you feel about our
first dance as a husband and wife being
to living on a prayer patrick that's a
terrible idea i don't know it seems like
a lot of bad things happen because of
this bangle it's an inanimate [ __ ]
object you're in there
[ __ ] objects dude i just had the
craziest night there were horses and a
man on fire and i killed a guy with a
trident
that idea is terrible pretend when you
have a signed warrant
now get the [ __ ] off my property
separate the tail from the body with a
firm twist you can discard the body or
you can save it for soup
my
there's a chance come on so you're
telling me there's a chance
you choo-choo choose me which is why you
have to come you have to come to karachi
it's your kids smarty something that's
got to be done about your kids you're
wearing a shirt that says new jersey new
jersey
oh god family
there was no baby it was full of cats
you want to know the secret to surviving
air travel after you get where you're
going take off your shoes and your socks
then you walk around on the rug barefoot
and make fists with your toes
i didn't realize you were in here with
someone so you will be this honest
legless faceless thing
[Music]
i hate this
it is revolting in all the years and
everything i've heard about that bangle
there was no mention of an inscription
do you know what it says
hey beva pull my finger we all go by
nicknames here right yeah what's yours
shark bait shark face
outstanding now let's fight all the
heads off and follow them up at the
corner
are you too good for your home
so
do you have a name
you that's my name
i know that you're pretty attached to
that rotting tree branch
but i thought it might be nice to have a
walking stick that
actually helped you walk i really value
your criticism but maybe we're being a
little hastier but you never never
pushed because i didn't care
stay alive no matter what occurs i will
find you
i'll find it if it's the last thing i do
i feel like i've been steady
it was
[Music]
it all started when a time travel
experiment i was conducting went a
little kaka
i have an announcement drake i had asked
you for getting just con
what huh
oh my god
santa here i know him
i just want to be sure that
you've been careful out there
i mean
be their monument be their angel
be anything they need you to be
or be none of it you don't know this
world a thing
this feels a bit more like you hmm no
capes
[Music]
i feel like i'm being crushed from the
inside out i can't believe you're making
this about you
we're with you
i'm with you to the end of the line pal
apparently there's such thing as bad
press and i don't like it what is this
there is no such thing as bad publicity
sweetheart
she chose you you were the chosen one it
was said that you would destroy this sin
not join them